a woody allen dock i hear is gonna be a
real barn burner
not good
not not not good
i don't know what to believe because
he's a brilliant filmmaker
but the movies all do have a theme don't
they have a theme
the films i mean there's many themes
they're some of my favorite movies ever
but he does seem very focused on the
young
ladies now this documentary is
supposedly so
harrowing it's very troubling they have
uh
adam curtis's new dock i got a watch
everybody loves it
can't get you out of my head or
something yes everybody loves it
anacotchia loves it right cump the whole
all the intellectuals uh
now this woody allen dock is on hbo
yeah it's called allen versus pharaoh
and supposedly the most disturbing part
of this
is um a scene
where he where the dylan is young
seven not good and
she starts a tequila company no she
she claims he abused her on camera yeah
and people are saying mia pharah might
have coached that but then there's a lot
of people that say man it's pretty
[ __ ] damning when you see a
seven-year-old kid
you couldn't get me to say anything
really at seven that i wasn't
truly you know i don't know
can you get a kid to say so i'm sure you
could
i'm sure people but i mean it's just
very sad
to think about obviously someone getting
abused in that way which is horrible and
then it's also very sad to think about
i mean it's just not helped by the fact
that he married his stepdaughter
and what's interesting about him is he
does strike me as a sociopath like you
never see him sad
in an interview and he never seemed that
happy he's kind of just very even
keeling hell this is what we do
we make a picture every year and uh we
do it in new york and
you know it got a little too pricey in
new york so now we shoot other places
and
i write every day like every interview
is like i i get up and i write every day
in this little moleskine
notebook and i and i rape my uh child
that's what i do i write in the
moleskine notebook and uh
i rate my kid it feels
i don't know i mean gun in the head ben
got in the head
is this guy guilty do you think woody
allen
was uh because farrah says she found
porn kid porn the
pictures of the i know when they were
married that he wanted to live in
separate houses
but just for his own work so he could
keep working on movies that seems like a
guy that would want the kids by
himself so it's a red flag right
right it's a red flag but the
kardashians all live in separate houses
that's true because they're buying
slaves
but what why would this we're delirious
at this point folks been up 16 hours
should woody allen marry kendall jenner
what if what if what if
woody allen married kendall jenner
and they and they just started a
tequila empire yeah what is the
now woody allen married his stepdaughter
suny previn
and who was cool about it yeah that's
that's kind of ballsy yeah
to go this is my [ __ ] and
i used to raise her but now i [ __ ] her
and that's the facts i didn't make that
up this is literally what happened
and if you have a problem with that [ __ ]
off yeah
and polite society was like okay all
right
odd the heart wants what it wants yeah
yeah that's what he said he said
something like artists create their own
moral universe
something like that yeah i mean so this
document when does this documentary drop
i think pretty soon and then it's kind
of all over for him
well i don't think there's a ton going
on now i think he's pretty much in the
de numa
of it yeah is there a trailer
i don't believe so you can't play it
anyway oh yeah that's right because hbo
i'm saddened by this because i like
woody allen but i don't like
uh him raping the kids
i think woody defenders always say they
go well he didn't actually raise her
someone else like raised her and he
never really had any contact with her
can i can i throw out a thing that heals
this sure sure
woody allen rapes kendall jenner
as you for healing
as a way to heal can he get out of the
dog house
crystalia came back out and we like
chris and you know chris had to
she said he had a sex addiction and
there's he's but every relationship was
legal and consensual and
we have always said on this show that
there's real no evidence or proof
of his
guilt that was satisfactory to anyone
there was no evidence or proof of his
kill
and yet he lost everything because of it
so i think that's a problem
in society i do i mean if i'm an only
child
if i had a little sister i wouldn't be
like here's chris you know i wouldn't be
like let's meet him
i wouldn't be the first thing i would do
right but still
that's okay that's still not killed
right
i mean so my my
my situation with all these things is
like
i mean should true dylan farrow
just say hey
it's tough because she's had this
horrible thing happen to her
and ronan farrow
is supportive dylan but he's a liar
and mia farrow is the one who
people woody says has orchestrated this
entire thing
it's a tough situation to be in
you know for everyone involved and
i i would have dylan farrow on the show
yeah and i will offer that dylan take a
look at this
take a look at this i want a clam strip
dylan i have one dylan i tell you right
now
if you want to tell a tale we want to
tell a tale
if you want to tell a tale whether it's
true or not you come right on a program
i don't care what you say
that goes for kendall jenner you want to
come in here and tell people about
slavery
you do it this is the new set for the
show by the way
hope everyone likes it what
is
let's ask a few questions that are not
popular if you are
a brilliant artist like woody allen
should you be allowed
truly if you're a brilliant artist like
woody allen
should you be allowed and this is going
to be very controversial
if you are as talented as he is
should you be allowed to start a tequila
company
you didn't think i was going to do the
other thing did you it's not that late
because you can't you cannot rape the
kids woody
don't do it
but don't you understand this is how the
[ __ ]
this is how every movie that we see now
we're gonna have to look at with
different eyes
all those movies where he was having sex
with high school girls they're gonna
seem wrong now
don't you see that don't you see the
problem here
all those movies where he was 45 and
sniffing the seats if
16 year old girls were gonna seem odd
now now they're gonna seem weird yeah
all those movies about
trapping young impressionable women in
horrible situations
are now in hindsight
going to seem bad
that's what's crazy